mmm well welcome to this video playing a
hospira look Nick from netherlands right
here and sloth let's play this for
change and we get the selector or select
our oriental and then i recently sorry
you're serious about that for the RCC
exactly with this move a six it's a
pretty solid way for black to blame hmm
not sure it's very very difficult for
white stone to make any headway against
this very solid set up h3 is designed to
prevent Bishop g4 and exchange on f3
playing in a rather restrained way but
um you cannot refute this with any
dramatic play anyway so
hmm yep maybe maybe the seafoam if i
take here i probably yeah you will take
with the sea pawn anyway i'm wondering
about this capturing a takes is a weird
louth after a four and here I thought um
hmm Bishop e3 why not actually
it's not badly placed on a three and it
has some potential to even go to d 6 and
2 h 2 i will do that it prevents pawn
age to it prevents v5 and yeah the
syntactic don't think so no so just
return but it's a very nice position of
the bishop here
the only drawback is that did it costs
them sometime so maybe the queen is on
be 694 I was thinking about be four 94
is quite quite annoying though pastor
let's go before before a day for it's
the most ambitious move
and now a foil threatened I think if he
must play 94 everything else looks weird
maybe Bishop f8 but ma'am I don't think
this is super 8 as well imply queen bee
three at stove intend to go away for but
Bishop of a design is availab available
oh this looks very passive okay here we
go need to do this anyway maybe still
nighty form yeah he can do that it's um
it's quite good at the end there's the
porn hang unfortunately
hmm yeah how do I keep the poor now even
it's not easy
okay yeah yeah I thought you would take
on here Queen takes takes and then a
four is gone but okay you just ignored
this possibility so now I'm just better
for nothing sb5 is under pressure and I
don't really see a good move now k Queen
a forum just odd wait wait wait wait
wait Queen a4 I can play anytime this is
good the stronger 96 prevents Knight b6
yeah this is a good move Knight b6 is
close to winning the Queen it can take
it of course but otherwise it would win
the Queen 96 yeah it's got no move
anyway and maybe I should have gone 96
now we can he can play Bishop f8 it's
it's like it's it's very very ugly but
still
Nina Bishop b5 still 96
yeah he has a hard time to to defend
this had threatened to this the rook so
now this one so it's all very nice but
how to actually win this may I think
this activation is this helpful and jam
mmm should I exchanged looks problem
yeah going for Roxy one
hmm how to defend the snow yeah the fact
it's impossible to defend amazing
33 seconds mmm Kim it's not it's not
easy to play I'm not sure about the
position I mean it's probably what
outlet it's not easy to do jack with
little time
yeah this is winning no check unless I'm
blocking stuff as possible of course
check time warning check green juice
have made yes black resigns yeah i'm not
sure i think it should be winning with
the extra clean for the two pieces yeah
okay but the computer is just some plus
form you always have some sort of yeah
trace of a doubt if it's really winning
but it did it should win winning it so
the purely defensive side up and it's no
no real fortress I have sir those pawns
that I can use and yet it's Janet Leigh
album it's too much the pawns and the
Queen together just for mating attack
maybe maybe Queen a for you I think he
had 96 is better I underestimated
bishops e6b five but ok it was good but
I could oops too much I could instead I
could also play here this first Queen
moves takes takes takes and then attack
this one it's also quite quite quite a
problem still very very strong pieces
yeah alright thanks for watching this